the Joe Rogan experience don't get close
to the Bison at Yellowstone don't try to
get a selfie with the Bison see their
video no as a nine-year-old kid he the
whole [ __ ] family they apparently got
within five yards of this [ __ ] bison
know they know come on and then the
Bison charge of the nine year old kid
went flying through the air the thing
about the nine-year-old kid landing
though it seems like she landed on her
feet so I'm hoping she's okay I haven't
read anything to the contrary so in my
mind she brushed it off and she's like
whoo can't believe I flip like that well
I mean it's like a you know if she
survived maybe a broken bone would be a
good reminder yeah
sprained ankle I want the kid to have a
sprained ankle yes but I just thought I
don't want the kid I want the [ __ ]
parent to get one of those weird
diseases weren't like when a twin falls
down her disease no okay it's like the
mom here it is watch you show you this
bison just to leave the newscaster boom
see how she lands on her feet though I'm
pretty sure she's okay watch this
whoo bang I think she's all right I
think she's all right
the thing is did it trample or after
these [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is the problem with zoos people and
and this city life that we live what
people do not know what the [ __ ] a wild
animal really is yeah you're not
supposed to go anywhere near those
things we're gonna find out they have
instincts to stop predation and their
instinct is to charge head forth with
this [ __ ] 200 but they do with a red
shirt on too like didn't you lunch ass
honey you should have jerked them she
stepped in for the little kid you piece
of [ __ ] okay over here you [ __ ] I mean
it's a 2,000 pound gigantic animal that
has to fight off wolves and mountain
lions and bears and and yep you're gonna
have your kid five yards away from me
you know we've had a lot of friends
musician friends that go yeah I want to
come out man I want to work harvest you
really don't know you don't know work
you really don't want to do this I mean
I want you to and I can make it a
pleasant experience for you
absolutely can I can make it go fairly
seamless but you're gonna learn some
things you didn't know about yourself
fact